if you're after a solid rtx 2070 super
then this pny xlr8r accelerates card
it seems to be a pretty decent option it
has good performance a
reasonable price point for the market
and good temperatures
and noise to go in it too let me show
you around it but first if you haven't
already consider subscribing for more
videos like this one every monday
wednesday and friday let's start with a
look around the card
this is a triple fan design with
translucent fan blades
making for a rather interesting look now
happily for some and unhappily for
others there doesn't actually seem to be
much if any
lighting or rgb here so rgb haters
rejoice and
people who love it look somewhere else
you do have a
relatively subtle design from the side
with obviously the geforce
rtx logo emblazoned as always
and the same goes to the back plate too
with a pretty subtle pretty nice looking
design now overall i'm pretty happy with
the aesthetics
although of course bear in mind most
systems you're only going to see the
side
and maybe the back plate so it looks
alright but what about the specs
well as you might expect it's an rtx
2070 super core so that doesn't change
what does change is the clock speeds
with this card you have a 1605 megahertz
base
and an 1815 megahertz boost clock you
also have
a six and an eight pin for power
although hardware info reckons that this
only draws about 200 or so or just over
200 watts
under gaming load so the 300 watts
maximum capacity you have here
gives you a bit of overclocking headroom
should you want to try and of course as
you might expect
in-game performance is pretty decent now
unfortunately i don't have many cards
actually here that i can re-test to give
you fresh numbers
with say the same driver versions or
equally updated drivers
and so what i'm going to be doing is
showing you the the results that i
collected for this card at 1080p
1440p and 4k and then you can make your
own
conclusions based on other results and
other benchmarks
whether this card is actually one for
you so starting off with battlefield v
this was tested with directx 12 on
and at ultra settings now at 1080p we're
looking at a pretty reasonable 128 fps
average with a good 1 low of 112.
1440p is a little step down from that as
you would expect
at 1 fps shy of 100 and again a good one
percent low here too
and at 4k we're looking at just shy of
60 fps at 57
average with a 1 low of 51 so a pretty
playable experience across the board
and of course if you were playing at
higher resolutions you can always turn
those settings down a bit
the same goes for called modern warfare
this was again at sort of ultra max
settings there isn't presets in this
game but uh either way we get 136 fps at
1080p
with again a good one low of 106. and
then
1440p is 95 with a 1 low of 78.
and again actually the 4k results are
pretty consistent across the board at
just shy of 60
either 57 or 58 here and again a good
one
low so a pretty smooth and responsive
experience
when it comes to pubg this one wasn't
quite as nice it was a little more
stuttery
uh which reflects in the one percent
lows across the board here with
while 136 fps average at 1080p only
knight at 69
fps in the one percent low area which
isn't great it is still uh more probably
a problem with pubg
since it's uh a bit of an interesting a
game
and engine but either way you still get
a pretty playable experience
although the one percent lows especially
at 4k were a little lackluster
when it comes to fortnite this was again
on epic settings this was in directx 11
mode
with multi-core rendering enabled and
this is the highest
1080p average results by far at 150.
the one percent lows are pretty low by
comparison to the average
but it was a very playable very
enjoyable experience
and the same goes for 1440p here and
even at 4k even though the average is a
couple fps lower
than the rest of the titles as for the
temperatures the excel r8
actually did a really good job here of
course this is a fairly large cargo that
does have a bit of an overhang on the
back where the heatsink extends past the
pcb
but the temperatures that i was seeing
was anywhere between 65 and 70 degrees
celsius while gaming in my
admittedly open air and reasonably
ventilated case
with that said the noise level was
actually pretty impressive
i really didn't notice it while doing
any of my testing
which actually is a very good sign of
course it's not
silent i mean it's got three fans on it
but it isn't
obnoxiously loud as for its price it's
listed for
just over 500 pounds in the uk and at
the time of filming
that's it sit pretty much right in the
middle of the road for an rtx 2070 super
and that seems to be a pretty justified
position you get some good performance
and you get some obviously good thermals
temperatures and
depending on your style preference you
might like that too
and of course well generally speaking
i'd probably recommend saving well over
100 pounds and buying an rx 5700 xt
instead
as you get 95 percent of the performance
for
25 percent less money but of course
if you do prefer the nvidia's rtx suite
specifically if you have some games in
mind like you know rtx minecraft or
even things like a bit of extra
immersion in the
called upon warfare campaign which is
fantastic by the way
you may prefer going with this instead
and of course you do get extra
performance
even if you have to pay a bit more for
it so as it stands this gets a good
recommendation for me
if you're set on an rtx 2070 super
it's a seemingly solid card with pretty
decent performance pretty decent
thermals and
noise and of course i do kind of like
the non-rgb aesthetic but
that's obviously personal preference now
with that said those are my thoughts i
would love to hear yours in the comments
down below what do you think
of this pny accelerate card uh and of
course what do you think of the rtx 2070
super would you pick up the
5700 xt instead or would you if you're
going to go this far
kind of go all in and get 2080 of 2080i
do let me know in those comments down
below and of course if you want to check
out this card i'm going to leave a link
to it in the description down below
that's an amazon affiliate link that
will take you to your local amazon store
where you can see pricing when and when
you watch this because it can and does
vary
there's also a load of other links in
the description you can check out from
other affiliate links for people like
overclockers uk
or vpn options stuff like streamlabs obs
and humbundle or there's merch hoodies
or t-shirts like this one or a load of
other cool designs
and there's also a load of other stuff
uh like patreon if you want to support
me directly too
otherwise there will be plenty of other
videos you can check out over there i'll
probably throw
the 2070 super versus 5700 xt video i
did with the gigabyte cards
up on the end card so you can check that
out but otherwise that is pretty much it
hope you enjoyed the video if you have
any questions feel free to leave those
in the comments down below
otherwise we'll see y'all in the next
video